si ya lograron ingresar a el capitolio y
lo que hicieron las autoridades fue
inmediatamente cerrar los túneles los
túneles que comunican precisamente al
capitolio con este el edificio del
senado donde está france24 estamos en el
edificio raso que comunica directamente
con el capitolio precisamente no
solamente cortan los túneles sino que
cortan también el servicio de metro
interno que tiene todo el complejo
legislativo acá en washington para
evitar precisamente que los
manifestantes pues lleguen a las
oficinas de los senadores y de los
representantes a la cámara que pueden
verse agredidos por estos manifestantes
que llegaron acá al capitolio después de
haber estado precisamente en la marcha
allá en la casa blanca y que lograron
entrar lo que se está diciendo es que
hay mucho miedo porque obviamente
entraron la fuerza no se sabe si
entraron armas y entraron municiones y
ya el vicepresidente mike pence fue
evacuado fue evacuado después además de
que hace unos minutos el presidente
trump reinará en su cuenta de twitter lo
siguiente dijo pence no tuvo el coraje
para hacer lo que se necesita para
proteger al país y a la constitución es
decir las autoridades al mismo leyeron y
se enteraron de este mensaje del
presidente de donald trump pues trataron
de evacuar y proteger al vicepresidente
mike pence que fue durante el acto de
conteo de votos electorales el que dijo
que él no podía tomar de forma
unilateral la decisión de no reconocer
los votos electorales esto generó
obviamente pues estos desmanes que se
están presentando en el congreso y
nosotros aquí en el edificio lo hace o
que es el edificio donde entre otros
pues tiene oficina marco rubio bob
menéndez y otros senadores bastante
importantes pues estamos ya cerrados de
este edificio no vamos a poder salir las
próximas horas precisamente por
seguridad y no vamos a poder
comunicarnos entre el capitolio y los
otros edificios también para evitar que
los manifestantes entren a estos
edificios y hagan
desmán sin embargo hemos visto en
imágenes en medios locales que los
manifestantes que han entrado al
capitolio pues están tomando fotos no
han tomado acciones violentas contra las
estatuas contra los muros contra
simplemente obviamente rompieron la
puerta de entrada para poder entrar pero
hasta ahora pues no se reportan muchos
actos de vandalismo en el capitolio más
allá obviamente de la evacuación del
vicepresidente
mike pence y de algunos otros pues
senadores y congresistas cristóbal te
encontrarás resguardado en uno de los
pasillos del capitolio como bien decías
entre algunas de las medidas de
seguridad que ya se tomaron anticipadas
la evacuación del vicepresidente
mike pence sabemos que no podemos estar
teniendo contacto con otras alas con
otros sectores de ese edificio pero
sabes si hay algunas otras medidas que
se podrían estar tomando
si de hecho en este instante me acaba de
llegar al celular un mensaje de alerta y
de emergencia extrema por parte de la
alcaldesa de washington muy el bayern
que dice que a partir de las 6 de la
noche habrá un toque de queda hasta las
6 de la mañana del jueves solamente los
trabajadores esenciales y los médicos y
los medios de comunicación podrán
transitar por la ciudad así que un toque
de queda que empieza a partir de las 6
de la noche a washington precisamente
para evitar más actos de vandalismo más
violencia entre estos simpatizantes de
donald trump absolutamente pues
impulsados por el presidente estático
que han llegado acá al capitolio y han
logrado meterse a las instalaciones del
capitolio y ha generado obviamente la
evacuación y pues la interrumpió sobre
todo
el acto de confirmación de el congreso
el presidente electo joe biden así que
en este momento no tenemos una agenda
clara de qué va a pasar porque se
suspenden en postres pues los actos
protocolarios de confirmación del
presidente electo yo bailé aquí en el
congreso tanto en el senado como la
cámara de representantes para poder
responder a esta emergencia que es que
los manifestantes logran darse al inicio
del congreso y empieza la evacuación y
obviamente ese cierre de los edificios
principales